[Music]
with the second pick the Denver Broncos
select Super Bowl champion Super Bowl
MVP Von Miller Von Miller
[Music]
what up this is Von Miller and this is
the Von cast on Bleacher Report in the
bleacher report app
um you can leave your questions in the
comments below about today's episode and
I'll get back to him in a minute
um today's uh episode is gonna be super
cool
got an episode with one of my guys one
of the biggest reasons why I came here
to Buffalo I don't think it would I
don't think it would be Avon in Buffalo
if it wasn't for him and another guy
that we had here
um I think the Buffalo Bills have been
the most swaggiest team for the last two
years and he's been the captain of that
team for sure
and without any further Ado this is my
guy Stefan did yeah thanks for having me
on I appreciate you bro like I said
before man this is one of the biggest
reasons why I came here I know we talked
about it before
um last year when I was with Denver
um it was like some talk about them not
picking up like my six year option and I
talked to Diggs like and not even that
was like that was like a serious
conversation but you know throughout
um throughout previous moments before
that like I had to talk to him and asked
him like Hey How's Buffalo how you
liking in Buffalo because my guy he been
all the way he been all the way around
the world he's been everywhere
um you know I've seen him out in the
streets multiple times
you know La Miami I've seen my guy
multiple places and I was like dang if
it's if it's cool enough for digs like
it'd be cool enough for me man and you
could just talk about some of those like
some of those moments that we had before
like I got here yeah it was crazy
because you know I'll see you in L.A you
you know you'd be in La a little bit and
be in Miami so it was just like this
damn like it was hard to convince you
you know the first time I tried to get
in the corner Buffalo he was like man I
don't know
and then like I guess things started
kind of turning into a corner when uh
you had like a little bit of
conversation with Denver you know
something like this man well you know
I'm still here and I think it was
waiting that was way back in 19 that's
yeah 20 2020 I think that was in 2020
um I had talked to him I was just asking
questions I had asked you know Diggs
Tremaine um I think that was like one of
my first times talking to Josh on
Instagram it's crazy because I hit
everybody up and everybody got back to
me and everybody said like the same [ __ ]
everybody's like man Buffalo cool man I
love buffalo this and that and it still
kind of felt like damn like
I don't know man it's Buffalo but you
know to like all the viewers and stuff
like when you get here like you just you
just understand it like you know it's
not really about like the clubs or like
you know restaurants or you know
anything like that flashy the people
here like Bill's Mafia the people at the
facility The Lunch Ladies like um the
infrastructure of the team from you know
like the uh the assistance to like the
janitors to the front office ladies like
everybody's so accommodating everybody
you know they want to see you do your
very best everybody's happy all the time
and I can understand why everybody you
know everybody loves Buffalo I saw it
was hard like I said it was kind of hard
to convince you because I mean it's kind
of hard to say no to La especially you
know I'm saying you spend time in L.A
laser La is a beautiful place it's a
perfect place to think it's going right
too and y'all went on a hell of a run
just to see your impact there I was like
this damn like I mean last time I was
like what could have been and I was like
[ __ ] when [ __ ] kind of stopped coming in
fruition when you was thinking about I
was like this damn we really we really
might get them I'm thankful you came you
came you came I'm thankful I came here
too man I would not have been here if it
wasn't for my dogs
you know back in uh 2021 when I was
going through like my um they were
singing about picking up my last year of
my deal and I was just you know I was
just talking to see how I was just so I
could like you know get you know like
just so just in case it did happen
because in today's you know League you
never really know and um you know I was
talking to Diggs and obviously you know
I ended up going to Denver I get traded
to the Los Angeles Rams and I go through
a whole run with LA and then um the free
agency comes I think free agency was
like
right around a month after the Super
Bowl so you know right at the Super Bowl
like you I mean you still have the Super
Bowl like you got parties here in Vegas
this and that and honestly like I never
really thought that I was gonna leave La
yeah like I was like bro like Aaron
don't you know everybody else in L.A
like Sean McVeigh uh lesney just La the
city in itself like it's hard to lead
that spot but Aaron Donald
um Jalen Ramsey Greg Gaines and Leonard
Floyd I was like bro no matter what the
record is no matter what happens you
know here in La no matter if we're good
or not like I could just ride out with
those guys for the rest of my career I
could like ride off into the sunset with
these guys bro we in La like we're gonna
get sacks regardless as me and Aaron
Donald never played with a guy like
Aaron Donald ever in my career he's the
best defensive player I played with and
I played with some guys I played with
Brian Dawkins I don't play with Chan
Bailey Demarcus where I gotta I don't
play with I don't play with a lot of
guys I put a key to leave Chris Harris
you know TJ Ward the whole no-fly zone
like I don't play with some guys but
Aaron Donald like to walk away from that
like it was it was tough for me and then
free agency come and the first day of
free agency for me was like oh you ain't
never been in free agency
yeah right it's crazy bro like I went
from I went from having 16 teams
potentially interested to 10 teams to
five teams to two teams and it's just
the Buffalo Bills and the Rams and it
all happened like so fast it happened
within like two or three days and I'm in
the Bahamas I'm in the Bahamas like and
I'm going through free agency in the
Bahamas I'm sitting with the phone like
right here while I'm sleeping like I'm
just waiting for any single call like
and um you know they called me about
Denver they had picked up Randy Gregory
you know and Coach McVeigh was calling
me asking me about like you know what's
going on while we waiting and then the
second day of free agency uh my agent
called me he was like Hey like Josh
Allen will give you a call like Diggs
gonna give you a call and I was like
damn like the Buffalo Bills for real
because I almost got drafted by the
bills I almost got drafted by the bills
that was the number three pick and I was
in number two so I almost got drafted by
the bill so I was like man the bill is
coming
and I started I hit you all right we I
think y'all FaceTime me yeah hell your
car just trying to get you on that one
like what's going on I need to I need to
see what's going on bro but you know I
just you know the whole hold up for me
was really just like leaving La and and
Aaron Donald and all of those guys man
but once you get here
you really just understand like what
makes Buffalo special you know the food
is crazy I think that's my biggest
difficulty here yeah is the food and
trying to stay like underweight but
trust me I know especially I know she's
all right I mean L.A they got good food
too so I just can't imagine being in
your situation because like walking away
from L.A took a lot yeah that's why it's
like I'm I'm that's why I say I'm
thankful you came here because once you
get here you really feel like all right
this is this is why they love it here
I'm saying but before you get here it's
like man I don't know because when I was
about to get traded here it was like it
was a big deal for me because I was like
this damn like the first time they tried
to chase me was in the season I told my
agent line man not right now I don't
know not right now because you know when
people presume when you're outside
looking in this was before like when we
had Halloween season they had went to
the playoffs but I was like this man I
don't know about buffalo [ __ ] don't
sound right right now then I was like
after the season I was like man it's
either I go there or it was like the
Jets or somewhere like that I'm like
this I'm gonna go to Buffalo and see
what's going on here bro we got [ __ ]
Josh Allen yes you know they had a they
had a whole like they got they they
Brandon Bean I'm a big fan of Brandon
Bean yeah and I talked to you about
being too when I was got when I had uh
when I had signed I asked my beans like
man being cool as [ __ ] yeah um I had uh
and been around other great jeans before
like less need and you know um George
Payton and you know John Lynch and and
of course John Elway so to get around
Brandon Bean who's you know he just
makes the position look like so
desirable and I talked to him about
Brandon bean and Brandon Bean said the
same thing about like uh Buffalo you're
gonna learn to love it like it's a great
place and honestly I'm sitting here with
my guy digs on the Von cash like we five
games six games into the season like I
love buffalo
and I'm happy and I'm happy I'm happy
I'm King here
um at this point in my career it's all
about winning games and being successful
and having another shot at a
championship and we got all those things
plus we got you know great fans and
great infrastructure of the team
everybody's Happy from coach McDermott
all the way down man it's it's really a
great place to be so if it's any you
know potential free agents or anybody
that's in Buffalo man you got you got
Diggs Josh Allen myself you know we got
some other teammates that might be
coming here I don't want to blow it up
all night right now we got some more
teammates that might be coming
um my offensive line Dion Dawkins like
before we got the whole nine here man
and you know if you if you don't want
your music producer
come over to the Buffalo Bill
they don't really have like a lot of
things to do at this point in my life I
just play golf and I play video games
all day and if I'm not playing video
games I'm streaming
um that's what my off day consists of or
if my son is here like you know I spend
most of my time with my son to see them
my son golf or video games like what do
you do on your off day [ __ ] uh it's a
busy ass day typically like you know we
got the body maintenance and stuff so on
Monday I got uh was two massages a week
basically uh two IVs a week two
stretches a week
um some other little minor stuff a
little hyperbaric chamber action little
stuff like that to try to keep my body
fresh you're getting hyper very I I had
a hyperbaric in Denver like you get in
there consistent I tried to you know I'm
saying I don't get as much as I can
because you can't bring no phone in
there so it's kind of like I get in
there when I can you know today a couple
hours
no I got one at the house okay so I try
to do that uh I pick out what I'm about
to wear prior during the week let me see
what I got going on for the weekend
because you know you pick your fit out
before it like yeah probably like a
my off day usually Tuesday every time
but you know at the end of the week too
we got fast Friday so it depends on what
day I try to figure out what I'm wearing
because I don't want to be it's been
times where I've been rushing out the
house and I was like man the fit don't
look right I I ain't really [ __ ] with
it so probably that right there and then
you know family time with my my daughter
in town we're spend that we'll play with
the Barbies and stuff like that don't
tell nobody about that but you gotta you
gotta do what you gotta do man stay with
the Barbie's a little bit uh family time
my mama come I'm saying God willing
hopefully my brother can come soon you
know I'll be going out to Dallas and
messing with him a little bit but off
day I try to get as much done dinner on
top of that work stuff you know like you
working on your off day this is probably
something you love to do but still on
your off day when you could be doing XYZ
you dedicate more time than something so
I try to give 30 to all the things I got
going on outside of football too so
despite all the other stuff like what
would the ideal off there oh [ __ ] look
for digs you know we got a lot of stuff
that we like we have to do you know it's
not really a off day but if you really
had an off day what would the ideal off
they look for look like for Stephanie if
we could teleport
if I could teleport I would fly
somewhere
you need some I don't know chicken
parmesan give me a whole lot of sun
because that's one thing about Buffalo
you might not get a lot of something
we've had a good season so far going
into October but you won't get a lot of
sun so I'll try to get some sun
somewhere
um maybe a margarita or something I
don't know I don't know it's all good
man I like working here
a little bit man oh yeah but I don't
know that's it for what what so did you
did you watch the Monday Night Football
game or no we had to you know it's
Chiefs we got the Chiefs coming up this
week play the Raiders you watched it
last night what was your takeaways from
uh I mean anticipated in the beginning
of the game Raiders came out with the
right mindset uh they were running the
ball officially Josh Jacobs is one of
the in my opinions he was running so
hard they had an early four from one
they went up top they went in with the
right mindset as far as like winning I
feel like towards the end of the game
they got a little bit away from running
the ball which had them we gave them
some success
um but I see like that crucial fourth
down play um it was kind of similar to
the one they had early on in the game
David went zero coverage everybody was
one on one and it had a little bit of a
miscue but just throughout that game the
Raiders had the right mindset it was a I
guess it was a little controversial with
that going for two compared to kicking
the ball but uh you know as a coach you
do what you think feels right especially
going in with that monster that
aggressive mindset [ __ ] they went
forward on fourth and one scored a
touchdown yeah why not why not be
aggressive but you know it could have
went it could have went anyway I think
you know obviously the Chiefs are a good
team you know what I'm saying uh Travis
Kelsey had four touchdowns I didn't miss
that that's very impressive and Patrick
Mahomes is obviously passing my homes
and they have a good defense you know
that their DC has like he has that
mindset of a Rolodex defenses right yeah
he runs a lot of different stuff try to
confuse the quarterback try to you know
trick you on what you see so it's gonna
be big for us to really hone in on what
we see get out the Huddle fast so Josh
can at least all right this is what I
think I'm seeing you know I'm saying
this is where we're in so we can play
fast but I did watch again the game was
exciting that was some exciting I've
been in the AFC West for 11 and a half
years man so you know I remember those
teams before the like the Derek Carr
yeah I remember the teams before like
Justin Herbert and before like a Patrick
Mahone so I'ma always be a fan of the
AFC West so whenever it's you know AFC
West games on the Telly realm and watch
it man and I'm a huge dare car fan like
yeah and everybody might not know that
but I am a huge Derek Carr fan I I've
gotten to know him throughout the years
at the Pro Bowl you know obviously
playing against them and he's just he's
such a great quarterback and he has so
much talent and he's really truly a good
guy off the field you know some guys you
know you can't really say that it's not
like you know him on the field but like
I know Derek Carr off the field man he
is he is genuinely a good guy man you
just want to see success for those guys
so when I'm watching the game and I'm
seeing Derek Carr go off and then I I
might I'm gonna take a step back when I
watch the Broncos game like was it two
weeks ago watch the Broncos game and
Derek Carr is running for 20 yards 20 35
years 35 yards scramble like he doesn't
do that yeah so when I saw him do that
it showed me like he had the opportunity
to go out of Bounce but he like very
back in and cut up the field and instead
of sliding he like dope I'm like bro
this is a different like Derek Carr
Derek Carr he really want this win and I
think that was I think they might have
been 0-3 by the time I was like bro he
really want that win like he got Devonte
Adams like he got he's trying to prove
like hey like this is the team like I'm
gonna take it over so when I saw him do
that I was like okay like Derek Carr's
back you know he had took it he had took
a step back from scrambling and stuff
after he got hurt like I think that was
uh I forgot what game it was but I think
one of the offensive llama like feeling
his leg broke his leg he kind of like he
kind of like took a step back and get it
but to see him like Hey like I'm back
running and stuff I'm like okay Derek
Carr really wants to win so going into
this game you know I see Derek Carr same
you know play fake going to Devonte like
he's patient back there even though they
got a great pass rush with with Chris
Jones and Frank Clark both of them are
my guys he's going crazy and see Derek
Carr like bro like you know he composed
and he really trying to win the game and
they get about 17 points I'm like okay
like they gonna win this game
but at the same time I was like bro
Patrick Mahomes like yeah yeah you can't
never count them out and he started like
you know he started doing things that
Patrick Mahomes does you know they
started making these making these little
catches you know flying Tom but then Max
Crosby had a crazy day too he had two
sets Chandler Jones China Jones is in
this lab all day too so I was like damn
like you know the Raiders really might
pull this one off but slowly like see
Patrick Mahomes like claws way back in
there Travis Kelsey like you said four
touchdowns 25 yards seven seven
receptions the hell of a player hell of
a player it's like you said like the
Raiders in my opinion was is a team net
their record won't reflect how good they
are 100 even said they'll lose some
games and then they they one of those
teams that probably could still be in
the mix I'm saying I feel like they win
their first game they they beat the
Chargers oh they are they one and four
they they lost a couple of games and
they beat the Broncos I know they beat
the Broncos I know like it's from a
seven point differential or something
that they talk about
it yeah they uh they uh they actually a
good team I saw him talk about it today
or I think on SportsCenter or something
but they were just saying that their
record won't reflect how good they are
because they have talent wise they got
all the pieces they're defensively and
offensively and the losses that they had
they were they were like close they they
haven't been blown out there it's all
came down to like one possession and
even the game last night it came down to
like you know that that call with
Devonte Adams and I'm sitting there
watching the game like bro that's a cat
she got even one hand feet in it could
have went it could have went both ways
and then the next play after that the
fourth down you know they run into like
they run into each other you know I'm
not a receiver like I think I'm I like
to think I'm a Rob receiver but I saw
Devonte go inside he's probably supposed
to take an outside release I was
thinking that cuz it's either he was
supposed to take an outside release or
on a Renfro wasn't supposed to go
outside because they was what we call
pissing in the same Coke bottle and
that's why they ran into each other
because he had a corner he had a post
you don't know am I in my mind Tay might
have been right and then I don't know
he was throwing the post to Devonte in
the middle of the field yeah so he was
he was imagining them being there I knew
that well man like you know I wanted to
I wanted the Raiders to win for obvious
reasons
um you know of course all those guys are
my guys man Devante Adams uh Derek Carr
you know all those guys I wanted to win
obviously because we planted cheese this
week
this might be even better you know um
Derek uh you know uh not Derek Carr but
Travis Kelsey over the years bro like I
got to know Travis Kelsey too swaggy off
yeah swag it off the field like that's
that's that he's become he's become one
of my guys I know like at the beginning
of my career like we had like a little
like online like spats and whatever I
said like you know the fake grunt I
think it was a fake gun cast anything
like that but I'm here to say on the
bleed the BR
um podcast the Von cast like Travis
Kelsey has created his own lane there we
go you know and I'm an Aries so I can
admit whenever I'm wrong you
I'm not like a horoscope guy but I know
like my son I'm an Aries like Aries get
along with other Aries Leos and like
Savage yeah what's happening that's how
I know I like this I get along with
areas like especially I'm not that much
into science with the but the people
that I'm around they accuse you like
even my assistant she loves trying to
she'll tell me like oh you don't get
along with this person because there it
is and I'm like this damn I thought it
was kind of cool but
I think it's I think it's I think it's
dope you know like have like at least
something that you you know you can have
especially on like any friendship or
relationship that you might have but I'm
here to say like I was wrong like Travis
Kelsey is in his own lane he's obviously
a Hall of Famer he he's created his own
lane him and Patrick Mahomes have a uh
let me think about it him and Patrick
Mahomes have a uh have a have a
connection or a relationship that has
never been seen before here in the
league and Travis you know I give it to
you man like hopefully we can get you on
the BR podcast
today's Devon cash one of these days man
but you have created a Hall of Fame
career man and kudos to you man and I'll
see you this week maybe we can talk
about it before the game maybe even
during the game but during that game
trying to block you yeah I mean you know
yeah
I don't want to create no you know the
bulletin board material but yeah
whatever you want to do
If he if they had to pick like uh
covering covering Travis Kelsey or
blocker oh blocking or Travis Kelsey
blocking me I'm you know I just you know
I'm sure it'd be 50 50. yeah there we go
I'm sure to be 50 50. but if it was
reverse and Travis Kelsey had to cover
me I don't know I don't know man I don't
know because in my heart like I'm fat I
feel like I'm fast like a kid I can do
all that stuff so back to the game like
it was obviously some controversial like
things that happened in the game you
know it's rough in the pastor not only
the roughing the pastor called on Chris
Jones
um but you know the roughing the
capacity call on uh on Tom Brady and uh
Grady Jarrett yeah two like both of
those was crazy what do you what do you
think about though it was tough because
I mean I know big Chris man and
obviously like from visual it wasn't
rough in the past I've seen people get
hit a lot harder but you've seen this I
mean specifically this year you've seen
a lot of guys like push a guy or shove a
guy and you barely really hit him you
feel like in the past that would have
never been a call but they've been kind
of throwing a trying to protect the
quarterbacks a lot this year he tried I
mean being I don't know how big Chris
Jones is dude I imagine he's close to
300 pounds yeah he kind of breaks
himself too he's trying to like try to
keep him he's trying to keep him from
Landing right on top of him while he's
trying to take the ball from it's a lot
to ask from uh d-line even though Chris
is crazy athletic like he trying to
strip the ball he's trying not to land
on somebody that's a lot to ask for
somebody playing football in general but
then like it's just so controversial
with the causes see that game could have
went another way it could have yeah and
it could have went totally just because
of that play like that we had a turnover
like and then this is just like I don't
know man like
granny my God I don't really see myself
I mean if you if I'm a team if you want
to see a quarterback game hey try to try
again I love time ready you know I got a
special relationship with John ready but
he was he was obviously mad but I think
the league put out a memo not too long
ago like falling on a quarterback won't
be allowed and he just all he really did
was like sling the guy like Tom Brady
then you know hit his head or anything
like that and I'm all about player
safety like you know if anybody that's
watching his play this this podcast
y'all know I'm all about player safety
and how to and trying to make the game
as safe as possible because I want my
son to play this game you know I want
other kids to fall in love with this
game the same way I fell in love with
this game and the only way we can get
there is to make it as as safe as
possible and I get like you gotta we
gotta take care of the quarterbacks but
at the same time like we got to be able
to like judge these calls or review
these calls but that's a slippery slope
too because once we start like reviewing
stuff if everything's reviewable and
like what I mean what we need to why we
need the riffs you know what why we need
to rip so obviously so obviously they
got to put in the call like okay if it's
a roughing to pass a call it should be
reviewable but they they did the same
thing with pass interference a couple
years ago they took away they had to
pass interference but even that that'd
be crazy in the future you might see no
reps refs might not have a job anymore
everything will be reviewable they'll
just be watching it from up top that'd
be crazy but I think they have pass
interference call but even then like as
a ref if I made a call whether you think
it's controversial or not they were
really pretty much sticking with the car
probably got reversed like once or twice
but all right and that's what I do man
you know
you know I I sat in the quarterback
that's like that's like my my main job
that's what I do I got to come into the
game of course we got to win that's the
most important thing and I gotta sack
the quarterback like this is what I do
and just my just my point on it is like
it's got to be reviewable but that's
always a slippery slope yeah like Diggs
has said it's a slippery slope because
you know they can put it in and then not
get caught and then while we why are we
stopping the game first but you know we
do a great job of making the game safer
we do a great job of making the game
more enjoyable so it's definitely
something that we should review in the
off season and we got we got Michael
Parsons right here this is my guy we got
Michael Parsons right here he said we
want to call this but we are caught
roughing the pastor laugh out loud can
we focus in and protect defensive
players too I don't think they care
about y'all anymore
I mean they have to bro they have to
like so for instance like the most value
position the most valuable position in
football is of course the quarterback
yeah and then you go to who affects the
quarterback most like the past Russia
Michael Parsons is coming up like his
contract bro his contract we're gonna
have to give him 55 million dollars 55
million dollars a year you don't
understand like it's it's it's it's
coming like it's coming like and if you
if we're gonna protect the quarterbacks
we got to protect the past versions then
you got to protect the wide receivers
and then the offensive line too like
everybody has a joint all three all four
of those positions they make the game
like like what it is the pass versus the
o-line the pass blockers the wide
receivers catch the ball from the
quarterbacks like those four positions
and the corners too you can't leave you
can't leave
but the corners are that's the most
difficult position in all of sports I
think it is I think give me your top
three hardest positions
so I think uh from a mental standpoint
obviously it has to be quarterback
because every the good quarterbacks like
you you you processing information like
real time you seeing this you gotta you
know be able to anticipate this route a
quarterback that's the most valued
position in our sport next I think
difficulty will have to be cornerback
because they guarding guys like you they
got guards like you and like other
talented receivers around the league and
I'm sitting here at five yards maybe you
know I might press them or I might be
off by 10 and I can't touch the guy I
can't hold the guy I gotta like sit here
and wait on him and I actually I gotta
react to him each and every move that he
do I got to react to him and I can't
touch him then the ball is in the air
and then I don't even know the ball is
in there I gotta judge you by looking at
the ball and I gotta turn around you
just got to be athletic you got to have
hips you got to have feet you got to
have everything
um and then number
three I'm not gonna say in my position
in your position because they said
because they I have my guy Akeem to
leave he told me a long time ago he's
like bring your position easy bro like
you basically your wide receiver on
defense you just rest rush now on his
line don't know what you're doing like
okay I I get it and then receiver you
know you gotta you got the quarterback
don't you the ball you got to have a
great quarterback yeah you know but I I
take a step back and I would say
don't say holama
argue with them every day it's tough bro
listen to this and be like well I said
it was dude it really is a it is a tough
position bro I'm telling you because I'm
going against the guys and I gotta I got
it from him you do a great job so how I
got a hard perspective I could get
blocked all [ __ ] game and then two
players out of the game I you know bust
a move or like slip the guy and I get a
sack Force One board and everybody going
crazy and this guy had to block he had
to really be on top of all of my
movements and react and he 100 pounds
bigger than me and so that's not hard
yeah but two plays and you bought him I
always say that the hardest is
quarterback one we went one for one
the next position was definitely not
um
they say corner but like I don't say
Corner why I don't say corner is because
we all grew up playing tag yeah and you
had to run away from somebody or you had
to kind of you know catch up with him to
tackle yeah I kind of equate that tag to
deviate a little bit so they gonna hate
me for saying that so I was I never go
cornerback second I usually go like
receivers so like it's hard to get open
and catch them it is it is it is bro it
is bro you're going against Athletic
guys that some of these guys some guys
and play receiver too my little brother
some of these guys know like what like
what you thinking like it's honestly any
position in football is tough like this
is this is a this is a I don't want to
say like a man's game because obviously
like women can play this game too it is
a tough challenging like game and um
from the ground up from all week from
preparing for this game from the mental
element of this game to uh you know the
the um the taxes like physically that
you have to pay week in and weekends it
is it is a tough game and all these
positions that you play especially at a
high level especially at a level like
digs or like Josh Allen or like Micah
Parsons like it takes a lot to get there
you know so I got to get respect to all
the positions you know I'm saying we
just had I just had to talk about it you
know it's it's you know I'm not I'm not
I won't say like just for the sake of my
conversation like you know I just say
like all these positions is tough but in
my opinion like you know quarterback you
know um corner I'm on the vodcast
um and uh what was what was the question
I had
has the way you play Defender change
since you came into the lead because of
the way they make calls honestly yeah
like it changed before when I first got
here you could just I could just do
whatever to the quarterback like I could
just grab them sling him down like I
could do whatever I want
um but now like it's changed like they
put such an emphasis on protecting the
quarterback obviously because you know
out of 32 teams 30 of these guys are
like the face of them yeah all 32 of
these guys are the face of my league
they're the future of our league so
obviously you got to protect these guys
but yeah it has changed and for me like
I put so much emphasis on the ball like
if I get a free if I if I dip a guy and
I got a free shot at the quarterback
like I'm not thinking like just blown
yeah I'm not I think I'm just like bro
just tackle the [ __ ] I'm not thinking
I'm not thinking like I'm thinking like
get the ball let me get the ball out
because I think like once you like put a
focus on the ball and not actually like
the player yeah yeah it changes like now
of course like if I can't get the ball I
just gotta tackle a guy but for me what
has always helped me like avoid like
rushing the passing calls or like
anything crazy versus the quarterback is
just I focus on the ball that is the
most important thing of a football game
I've seen it in the Super Bowl yeah so
that's what I'm thinking about bro I'm
going after the ball bro so yeah it has
changed the way you play I got a
question though like
say because like you said protecting
y'all but at the same time put you in a
very vulnerable state for like a
quarterback like those mobile
quarterbacks like a guy like Josh or I
like Pastor my homes who he not just
getting tackled like a normal guy look
you ain't just bringing Josh down by
just tackling on you know how you could
probably tackle a smaller quarterback I
feel like I got a question like do you
feel like they should make it some
parameters like if I got two hands on
him he shouldn't be able to throw this
ball or he shouldn't be able to do what
a lot of the good ones do yeah let's
take off a guy yeah Josh do it all
exactly yeah I mean
no it's always gonna have to be like me
I gotta put the guy on the ground and
get the ball out I think it'll always be
there and I think it's rough I think
honestly we kind of overreacting to
these roughing and pasture calls because
like it's been two crazy ones like in
this but I think over time like it'll
settled down like our competition
committee will figure it out and um yeah
I've been in the league 12 Years bro
like things like this they always like
they always like work theirself out like
any safety issues that we have in our
league they always like what worked
themselves out I think that's just where
we at like this it'll work everything
will work itself out and I'm a pass
Russia and I'm going to the quarterbacks
each and every week and I just know like
you know [ __ ] like this it will work
itself out but you know this last week
we got we got a dub yeah and it's all
about dubs it's all about dubs in the
league we got a a big dub over the
Steelers
um Josh Allen had a career day 224 yards
that's a matter I think he had that in
the first half he ended with like 424
right yeah he said he had 424 yards 424
yards he didn't even play the third
quarter so he would have probably had
like oh yeah it probably been some
matching he probably he would have
easily broke like this he would have
easily broke 500 yards at least you know
do you in my opinion this is my question
to you
from watching Josh Allen before you on
this team did you think he was as good
as he is right now I knew he was good
um
we play we play uh the views in 2019 I
think we play the bills in 2019. he was
on this he was here yeah yeah we played
the bills in 2019 I think so yeah yeah
[Music]
sometimes we played the bills in 2019
and I I just remember like going against
Josh and him he was running around
usually like quarterback and running
around to step out of Bounce and just
like ran around and took it was like 60
yards I'm like bro like who does that
bro like what are you doing like he went
crazy that game so I knew and then like
over time just me being a fan of the
league and like eventually I want to be
like a GM so you got to pay attention to
college and like other players around
the league so I've seen Josh's uh
Evolution throughout all this time and I
saw like in particular like last season
like he just continued to take these
steps so I knew like Josh was Josh Allen
but seeing it up close and personal like
hearing practice like being around them
in the locker room like [ __ ] uh
seeing them like kicking at his house
playing Blu-ray and like van around like
just being around them in general it
made me it made me really realize like
hey this guy is like special it's not
just like one of those it's like one of
those flute gears what do you how you
feel about Josh of course of course we
got you know we got this coming up in a
segment can't stand them yeah uh Josh
got one of those like fairy tale ass
stories you know like it's kind of weird
but you know a kid out of Wyoming Big
Arm you know saying going in the draft
and then his first couple years he has
some success and then like I kind of
knew about Josh already because they
came and kicked our ass in Minnesota one
year like you know we had we were 17
point favorites going into the game and
we got the Bobby right after so we got
our mindset on [ __ ] like Buffalo coming
we going all right we're gonna walk down
and we go to the bar so they came in
they came in with the right monster I
think they went up two scores like in
the first or second quarter like this oh
hold the [ __ ] up hold up what's going on
and then I was like this [ __ ] like y'all
better [ __ ] together they bout to beat
the [ __ ] out of us and then next thing
you know like we're down like 20 points
or something crazy and I'm like this
damn we bought it really bought a really
really to the bills I'm like [ __ ] well
game's over now bye week here I come and
then that was my only thing I had
registered in my brain as I was about to
get traded so as I'm about to get traded
and I had the team to choose from
I was just I had a I had a clear image
of Josh Allen in my brain and then like
they had went to the playoffs against
Houston the year before and like he had
a hell of a game like he like caught a
touchdown like a pastor he threw him a
touchdown he had threw some [ __ ] he had
ran I was like I don't know what y'all
talking about but he a winner like he a
dog yes yes so I uh when I got traded or
whatever I had met him in the offices
I'm like damn he got you know how you
meet somebody and it's like
you might not like immediately like
click but it's like this damn I he cool
as [ __ ] like I could I'm saying like
this [ __ ] all right so I kind of went in
with that mindset and then moving
forward as a season started progression
I was like this [ __ ] like Josh Josh cool
as [ __ ] like we would play the game
together like little kid [ __ ] that
adults usually don't typically do and I
was like damn like I [ __ ] with Josh and
then like as a season went on we had a
lot of success together and him throwing
me the ball and [ __ ] like that like I
owe him a lot of credit to my success
especially going into a new new team
where you know I'm saying a lot
sometimes [ __ ] don't go right yeah I'm
saying and this is one of those stories
that well it did yeah when I first and
foremost always thank God but then I
always give a lot of credit to jobs like
even that first year he won't tell you
this but that first year I felt like uh
I felt like he
he kind of like changed my career to the
point where I wanted to be I wanted to
Blossom and I wanted to turn into one of
the top receivers in the league and he
helped with that so for Christmas I had
got him a little uh I had bought him
like a watch like a nice little nice
little watch yeah a little uh what was
it it was something it was something
small I asked him about it I bought him
a little watch for Christmas he was
happy about it but it was just something
that I was like [ __ ] bro you you were
part of My Success so I wanted to show
my gratitude to him and you know about
not only that just getting open and
catching the ball for him because my job
is to keep them looking good too yo bro
100 like I told you like I like to play
GM sometimes I like to just think like
like you said like just because it's
supposed to go right like it never go
right but when I seen like when I saw
you like get traded here like with Josh
Allen I saw like the jumps he was making
Bros like everybody take them I think
that's your Instagram oh yeah yeah I was
like bro you in a good spot like Josh
like for Josh like to see that that's
all he really needed like he didn't have
like you know he had great receivers but
you know Stefan Diggs bro like that's
all that's all they really needed Brian
to see y'all like take off like that bro
it's appreciate that bro it's [ __ ]
crazy bro for sure that's why I say it's
a fairy tale story like if it could
happen this way for everybody I wish it
would you know what I'm saying
especially this league that we in now I
feel like it's different in like 10
years ago 10 15 years ago because you
see guys why things are out in their
career like as far as like being with
the same team or just like just a little
[ __ ] like that so for me it was like
really
at this point you take control of your
life you're the CEO of your life you
learn how you see fit and if you're not
happy you got to make the necessary
changes and if you see more for yourself
or you want just some enough some type
of different role like you see a guy
like Minka Fitzpatrick who was in Miami
originally you know I'm saying Hell of a
player and he just felt like damn like
I'm not going to Blossom in this
situation I need a different situation
he went to the citizen he's one of the
best safeties in the league he took
another step Miami had him at corner I'm
saying so it's just like little things
like that you can kind of see yeah some
guys sometimes it didn't work out for
guys we wanted to go other places but
I'm one of them and you know as example
Mika finish practice just guys go in and
said man I need something different and
you shouldn't you should never feel
wrong for that never really you should
always bro if you if you I would I'm
always a fan of like betting on yourself
I know we talked about Lamar Jackson and
you know the things that he did man so
that just follow along with you just
said bro you got a bit on yourself you
got to believe in yourself but back to
the Steelers game like [ __ ] got chippy
bro like oh yeah yeah
like your reaction to see like Kenny
Pickett like put push Shaq Lawson like
that I think
from my point of view it's kind of like
similar to the Ken Dorsey situation when
they saw him like you know like go a
little bit uh I liked it [ __ ] he's not
my quarterback though so he's still the
Ops but as he as I saw him do that I was
like this that takes a lot of guts from
a quarterback position to Pusher
especially one like that like as you
know Shaq ain't no sucker out of all the
people
yeah so like it shows like he tough like
he I mean and his teammates came and
backed him so you gotta one give him
some respect and two be like all right
he might got some I always say they got
some [ __ ] with him yeah he ain't your
regular little running in the middle
take it I'ma just take it on the chin
yeah when I said when I saw her bro I
was like okay
you know they I always like to look at
both perspectives like okay they down 38
to to three and I don't think it's so
much about like the hit that Shaq had on
him I think it was so much like hey this
is our score or the situation that we're
in is not acceptable like this this
ain't gonna be us like this is my first
start but I'm gonna show y'all like I
don't I'm not accepting this [ __ ] like
I'm gonna tell you like this ain't this
ain't good with me and then not only in
that play like the scuffle uh versus uh
when when um when James Daniels had
pushed Hamlin like yeah they went crazy
over that [ __ ] too I think that was just
another like case of like bro like we're
not We're Not Gonna accept this [ __ ] I
know this I know what the score look
like bro but this [ __ ] ain't gonna fly
and I was on the sideline right here bro
I came up of course I'm not gonna get no
scrum like I don't like to say I'm too
old for [ __ ] but I'm doing over that
[ __ ] bro hey
300 pounds you guys you got you got 20
you got [ __ ] 12 300 pound plus guys
right here from both teams like going
around pushing guys they're doing I'm
not bro I'm not getting in that bro like
I love of all my guys I love my
colleagues but I'm not getting in there
but I walked up after I was like bro
what are y'all doing and I think it was
cold on the Steelers team it's like bro
it was on the bills like miked up today
I was like bro what are y'all doing what
am I doing he looked at me he said I
don't know he literally said I don't
know I don't know what's going on like I
ain't know what's going on either I know
I saw I know I saw my God damn more
though he like slapped the guy like he
like he like he like held it back and he
like slapped the guy bro it was so funny
bro and I you know at this point in my
career bro you like look at the Silver
Lining and everything bro when everybody
started fighting I was like bro you but
these young guys crazy it's crazy I
think that's example of Buffalo too
though like like as our team you see
that video like our team don't be having
that [ __ ] like all our youngest they
they on that they trying to see what's
going on make sure everything everything
I'm too old for that [ __ ] like somebody
pushed me the wrong way out the ankle
roll or something I can't have that I
can't I love him and I know I digress a
little bit but you know I wanted to talk
fashion a little bit like been on the
fashion been on the fashion show forever
bro and you know I got calamari he wore
this this uh I don't know what it was he
wore this green this green uh
this green pantsuit let me see before
the game and like oh that's that's the
deal
out but that's Dior I actually seen it
when I was in the Dior store and it was
uh I mean I I don't I would wear
something I would wear it you know I
don't know you're saying maybe y'all
don't like it but you know uh his fish
usually be great I like this fit too
it's not for everybody I feel like it's
eclectic and you know I'm saying as long
as he being himself I'm gonna embrace it
but I actually saw this and if I'm not
mistaken it is Dior and [ __ ] man when I
said when I seen color put it on bro I
was like bro this is something I would
wear too like exactly you know I like
wearing I like wearing [ __ ] that like
everybody you know what I'm saying can't
pull off like pull up Vaughn 50 Beyonce
fit right now we had that on there last
week
uh who didn't like it on the team
somebody was talking about Tim soda
timing but you know people already
knowing bro they don't be knowing bro
yeah Kyler I'm like bro like this is
hard bro like this is hard and some
people were saying like if you were
interested a football game game like how
could you be focused honestly what you
wear to a football game has nothing to
do about how you play honestly I feel
like you should dress nice because Deion
Deion Sanders said it a long time ago
like if you dress good you play good you
know saying if you play good they pay
good you know what I'm saying and like
Colin bro he's just saying body he
embodying that and I feel like if he was
if we was rappers or singers or
entertainers in any sport I mean of any
like type of field or genre or a concert
or our our biggest day of the week is
game day so whenever you're going to
game day you should always dress to the
T you should always take advantage of
the spotlight and the platform to go out
there and dress nice and you know I like
I like Colin Murray's fit I've always
liked yo yo fits and I'm like the bills
for everybody I always like people you
know dressing dressing up and and
putting on something that you ain't
never really seen before Cam Newton did
it forever you just you just see stuff
like you you're able to like take this
platform and like really make it your
own because whenever you dress you
really um you really can like promote
you can really like promote yourself you
can show who you are without saying who
you are you know what I'm saying so all
my expression I'm always for like you
know guys dressing like that I see I see
you I see you on a daily basis I'm like
this because like when it comes down to
style people don't really understand
especially when it comes down to
eclectic not every not everybody's going
to agree with what you're wearing but
that's why they're not wearing it I feel
like [ __ ] long as you being yourself I'm
saying you know when somebody being
theyself like like for example I see you
Bob the Carhart [ __ ] a long long time
ago you could tell like but you also
kind of grew up on that too like that
was just like that's your swag so when
people be in themselves like you can
always I can always thoroughly like be
like I'm gonna Embrace that I respect
that because you've been yourself like
your style is your style that [ __ ] not
for everybody well my Fashion Icon is is
Lil Wayne right oh yeah and I've been
I've been a I've been a little Wayne fan
since since I was a little kid and I saw
a little Wayne dressing you know he just
really put on he really put on [ __ ] that
he like he put on [ __ ] that he feel like
is is cool and [ __ ] that he it might be
whatever it might be expensive it might
not be expensive it might be uh
expensive like hat or it might just be
like a two dollar hat from somewhere
else he worshiped that he liked and when
I saw when I saw him as a little kid
that always like was my inspiration for
fashion like I'm just gonna wear what I
like not necessarily thinking about
Brands like it could be a it could be a
high fashion brand or it could be just
you know a brand from the dollar store
I'm aware what I'm gonna wear it like
[ __ ] that I think is cool man and I
always enjoy like people wearing [ __ ]
that they think is cool money don't
money don't give you stop it don't
because a lot of people with bread too
they know they had a they had a Louis V
hat
you know just because it is what it is
don't make it like this how you wear a
lot of [ __ ] too like I could make this
hat like this hat might not be much but
the way I wore it'd be like this damn
that price super expensive no I just got
this from the gas station bro in a
bigger and a big example of that is like
my God uh DeAndre Hopkins and my guy
Jamal Adams like that go to Walmart and
like chill swag they go to Walmart and
put some [ __ ] together like it look
didn't look like a men's section yeah
they look like damn what is this like
that's what it's about bro like that and
I've seen those guys do that like I like
I like I wanted to like you know really
like
Empower them like bro like this is what
it's about bro it's not always about
like high brands of course High Brands
and high fashion brands is cool but like
bro you want to wear [ __ ] that's hard
yes there we go there we go
Beyonce sent me that man okay you gotta
listen not everybody not only has the
will to have it but you gotta have the
confidence and people don't be people
with lack confidence that's why they
dress like other people when you're
dressing like yourself that's when you
could be like this nah I'll put this
[ __ ] on I got this [ __ ] together and I
got from Beyonce yeah but rather Beyonce
from Beyonce Beyonce whether Beyonce
send it to me or not bro like I still
would like wear this [ __ ] because it
just it just stand up and it was raining
that day like I was just like bro like
just the rain gonna fall off this [ __ ]
Bro all right Beyonce said he's got the
she sent me the whole thing I'm like bro
like yeah I'm a I'm gonna ride this [ __ ]
I respect that but bro you you've been
the king you always been the king of
memes of the NFL bro like you always
going viral it's always it's always
something like the memes like they love
you bro and you can't we can't have a
social media segment without looking at
some of your emotions let me see
something man embarrass me all right I
think another embarrassing right yeah I
think it's I bro I just it just go with
it bro
all right uh this is my teammates and
they're probably some of the problem
because they're on a silent you don't
understand you've been there yeah you're
going to that weird place of
you know I'm saying battling out there
on the field and then you come full
circle on the sideline and then you like
after a big play I've seen you make some
of the biggest plays I've ever seen in
my life like when you strip strip Cam
and just like plays like that you go to
another place to be like this this is
what I work hard for this is why I feel
like I'm him I'm saying him is a new
thing like him ain't always been a thing
but like I mean we got a lot of people
saying hey you know there's a lot of
them brothers
when I saw you come up because this
obviously was our first like real game
playing together bro and you know Jalen
Ramsey that's that's one of my guys too
and I've been around them and I've seen
him like ball out I've seen them locked
down guys then when you when you come
when you made the plays that you made
against Jalen bro and before using off
the field because I'm on defense I'm
getting ready to go and I always like to
be down on the offensive side so I had
to walk I don't have to walk that far
and before you even got off the field
bro he was like I'm him I'm him I'm him
I'll be like bro bro he really bro he
really here bro he really him bro like
bro bro I like I like I like I like
laugh bro because it was just like it
was just so it was enjoyable to me to
like really like witness like like
greatness like play by play Because at
my at my at my at my 12 years in Libra
like like I said I look for the Silver
Lining at every moment and to start the
game start the season off like that bro
and like bro and Jalen one of the
biggest like trash talkers there is bro
and like you saying like bro I'm him
coming off it like that amplify
everybody else around you bro and they
see like the back of that because you
started off on the field then you walked
to the sideline dude I think the defense
is on there and they see you like keep
it going bro like it ain't I don't think
you I don't think you try to make these
these viral moments they just they just
come to you bro they make it even more
dope bro that game was just like a you
know we went in the mindset like you you
was on a sideline kind of preaching
something I've never seen that don't
blink that don't blink is real I'm
saying it's something that resonated
between everybody and it was just like
those moments like especially that game
like presumably you know generally the
best corner in the league in town Bar
None you know I'm saying so as a as a
competitor you know I'm saying you take
that as a challenge for yourself you
know if you if you wanted the best are
you the best you got to show it you got
it I gotta show it and that was more so
for me you know I know Jalen I'm saying
he's a hell of a player too as well like
he is no no doubt one of the best in the
league and you know I saw that as like
not only something for my teammate
because
as a leader on my team as a captain
watching I gotta leave my guys the right
way you know I'm saying as cool as I am
with people I still gotta leave my guys
the right way I'm standing on business
at all times so you know I'm saying
giving the energy to my team and that
kind of thing too it kind of like I
think it works for a circle too it does
bro and like you know energy but like
that [ __ ] rub off I've been on so many
different teams running energy it really
like rub off on your teammates bro I
remember in 2015 like Aqib Talib Chris
Harris we was outside at the table
Emmanuel Sanders too he's and the kid
was like Hey like I'm gonna win MVP and
then like Chris Harris went to like
Brahma win MVP they're like man who's
awesome this is before the Super Bowl we
all playing dominoes at the table at the
table and like brown may win MVP and I'm
like man I don't know what y'all talking
about bro like MVP like we was just
bullshitting at the table and then you
go into the game bro and we we all had
great games and then for like me to like
win like Super Bowl MVP bro it wouldn't
have got there if it wasn't for a key
bro it wouldn't have got there for a
keep like starting it off you know
battery so I'm always for like like
energy rubbing off on everybody bro you
won't like that's what you want on your
team and all the great Super Bowl teams
that I've been on have always possessed
players like that people like that and
moments like that for sure this next one
right here is the emotional post game
after after Minneapolis that Minneapolis
miracle and I you know I I like uh
Justina Anderson and I saw this
interview
I saw this interview bro and I can only
imagine like bro like bro to for the
game to be over with and you have this
moment like this bro like I feel like I
felt I felt that bro 100 bro this is
real though like it oh no man I still
kind of look back and was like this damn
cuz like y'all don't know like it wasn't
really just this moment but it was like
like just throughout That season Like
That season was like we had a good
season but like individually like some
stuff was going right some stuff wasn't
going right you know I'm saying you
worked so hard like I worked so hard to
try to make it like make it go right and
to see some things go right and some
things don't go right and then we're in
the playoffs you're making a playoff
push and then like you know our first
game is New Orleans like that was a good
ass team that we played so uh they
supposed to win Super 100 100 they were
supposed to win the Super a couple years
so for that to happen like I saw Stephen
A hop on like I hopped on with Stephen A
probably like after the game or sometime
at that point he was he was telling me
that uh do you feel like to play with
someone lucky and at the time I played
it cool like I was like it's not like
you know I'm saying like I feel like XYZ
so looking back on it like I wish I
would have told him that damn like one I
wish let me see your ass do it you know
I'm just joking but I wish I would have
told him that like for real it was
divine my purpose like that was me just
falling in line with my purpose for the
things that happened the way they happen
because uh it could it could have went
another way but it didn't so like I got
really emotional at the game because it
was like they don't know how hard that
season was for me mentally and for
something like that to happen it was
like this damn God is real you know I'm
saying it's a blessing at the end of the
tunnel sometimes you just don't know
right it's only it's only a few that can
really like feel that bro like you know
when I was when I was in that those not
nothing you know similar to that but
when I had moments like that where I
could just reflect you know at that
moment when you're doing an interview
and you're talking to somebody you just
were instantly taking back to Little
League football college all the hardware
that you put in it's just like a
flashback like right for like all the
struggles where people said you couldn't
but somehow you made it happen and now
you're on TV and you just did this for
like it just all hit you once so I like
I felt that for real I felt that for
sure but I think the meme has said they
are but I want to grow with Josh I want
to grow with Josh
hey Josh John I know you feel the same
way we had Josh on the show last week
bro and Josh bro he loved you to death
bro they be uh always sending to me when
like a new album drop or something like
that like this I think it was one like I
think I just seen it and somebody sent
it to me they said will you hear Rihanna
about to perform at the Super Bowl and I
was like is that I mean I still might
cry with Rihanna
brochure I mean this bro Rihanna's Super
Bowl hopefully hopefully we can it's
going crazy hopefully we can take a
little break out there and see what's
going on but I'm joking brother the
kicker from this the kicker from the uh
Bengals did that with our Super Bowl
game he waited outside and watched Dr
Dre and uh I think it was it was 50. no
I watched it no the kid from the Bengals
then go in for halftime he sat out there
and like watched the whole thing on the
bench that's hard yeah like I mean he
always had to go in the locker room yeah
he ain't got no adjustments
you know another thing too that you go
viral for are your genuine touchdown
celebration yeah I remember the first
the very first one that I seen was you
caught a touchdown and you did like the
little digs back when hitting them folks
was like everything bro
I've seen all that [ __ ] bro I think he
was used to the young boy then yeah my
first game my first game uh when I first
go to the tub man I was like I remember
that one like it was yesterday but this
one right here Stephanie Stefan Diggs
hit that oh that's genuine we was uh so
all of my celebrations come from my
teammates like if they talk about
something during the week they'd be like
Steph you gotta hit it you got it I'll
be like first of all I gotta [ __ ]
learn the dance move like I can't do I
can't just go out there rolling the dice
so actually like we uh choreographed
this like my teammates just showed me or
whatever and we did something last year
against Tennessee I had to remember the
hardest part is like if I've learned
something right now I could probably
like do it yeah but when the game and
you gotta remember when you're gonna get
that you never know ain't no music or
not you just kind of gotta do it on the
fly one two three four five six so bro
wide receivers is different I remember
uh I remember when obj hit like the uh
the moonwalk he got some of the best
Corey guys it seemed like he said he had
them since he was a kid he was talking
he was talking to Chris Brown he was
talking Chris Brown in the locker room
on FaceTime they was talking about the
moonwalk like before he hit it I'm like
dang like wide receivers really put so
much stuff into like these celebrations
and they always had some great
celebrations bro that that one was great
bro like I said before the the digs one
bro like when I was like oh yeah his
last name Diggs at the end so you Court
you choreographed him like yeah this was
when I was young when are you young
celebrated was everything it wasn't even
so much about a touchdowns more about
the celebration when you're young now
I'm just I'm just trying to rack up them
tugs now man I might hit a little
something bust a move but [ __ ] I'm
trying to score now man I mean with me
when they come to celebrations bro like
I I'm at a point now like where I just
can't hit it's got to be the right
moment for a celebration like I wouldn't
say like I just feel like where I'm at
like especially when my career and like
the expectations that I have for myself
like not anybody else ex not anybody
else's expectation for me but just my
expectation for myself if I get a sack
and we and we down like in the in the uh
in the Baltimore game bro we down 20 to
three but I'm not about to do a
celebration yeah I can't do it I just
feel like just in my opinion like I
wouldn't want to see like me do a
celebration when we losing like that you
know what I'm saying I just jogged off
the field well if it's if it's a moment
like if I get a sack Force fumble for
the game like bro oh you gotta go crazy
I'm gonna go crazy bro I'm gonna run
around the field I'm gonna do all type
of [ __ ] and for me it just happened like
I do I dance all the time anyway I
didn't say practice oh no I've seen it
practice or dancing locker room you
don't get tired I'm just the music I'm
just a music like dance like type of guy
bro like so I always like dancing I
always like being around music I like
loud music and it just it's just one of
those things that keep me going so I
always had like these dances in my
pocket so whenever the game come when it
happened it just happened it just it
just go and honestly for me like
especially like in this last past game I
got a sack on second down like third
down camera bro I was tired bro not
actually the play like but from running
around and then like yeah I'm like damn
bro like this [ __ ] is a lot so I've been
trying to save my energy too and I'll
just be trying to wait for the right
moment I've seen I've seen I can attest
until
um the real truth that he the loud music
thing is a real thing because we listen
to the loud music at 7 A.M you'd be in
the room by yourself
by yourself and one day they was like
this damn like y'all hear that [ __ ] and
I was like this yeah I wonder who over
there they probably over there lit so I
went over there I was like this nah I'm
all in there about himself just turned
up foreign
once you hear like loud music where it
just it just it's just energy in itself
it's Just Energy in itself man another
another moment that you went viral for
is um you know when they had Hard Knocks
and everybody asked you know your
teammates on the Vikings uh who would
who would they least like to date their
sister and everybody everybody was
unanimous and they said digs I think
they was hating too though I said I
think it was Hayden because back then
that Team bro that Team bro I could have
picked some of those guys and I didn't
like like four was like what am I I
think I was just an easy target right
here man don't believe those guys those
guys are liars only person that's a good
guy right there that they're showing is
somewhat Adam I'm feeling yeah for sure
that's my God on this Bills team like oh
I love them who who with you which which
I would say Let me let me write this way
which bill would you allow I want to do
rather not but who's a
presume good guy on his team
I don't know
not not uh I gave Davis
I need somebody to go to go to mass on
before the game and stuff I've been
around Dawson Knox Dawson's not bad
right oh ready to get him Reggie oh man
he's good good guys I think uh you know
Tommy Doyle is cool
I like Mitch Morris yo give me Mrs Gray
I love him
that's Mitch's body we don't even refer
to him as a mitch give me no give me
give me who you at least uh
I mean besides you and myself you know
I'm sure that I'm sure they say I'm sure
they say me or you on there I would
probably go probably Isaiah man like
Isaiah
Isaiah McKenzie no I just wouldn't do it
bro I'm sure me and you would probably
lead those like this but I wouldn't like
you know if I had to pick like I
wouldn't you know I've been around
Isaiah on two different teams and he's
the same guy that's not good oh dude you
know I wouldn't I wouldn't let Isaiah do
it for sure I'm telling a little dirty I
can't wait now
um you know you posted back to like
another serious note which is another
another reason why like you know like I
[ __ ] with you for real is you posted a
photo of you watching you know the chief
celebration in 2021 and that's a hard
that's a hard moment to be in like
confetti dropping you know I've been
there one time it's just like bro I want
to get out of here bro but like
for you to like sit here and like take
that [ __ ] on the chin I mean that shows
you like you got some resolve and that
showed you like bro you knew like I'm
gonna be back here yeah I'm gonna be
back here this [ __ ] gonna be different
for you to like sit there and absorb
that in bro like that that took a lot
bro like this went viral and it was
super inspiring it was inspiring to me
and I'm just sitting here I'm just
sitting here on the couch watching it
man I'm like what was uh like to post
that what was your intention behind it
it was tough because like my God [ __ ] of
course I got hella feedback from that
[ __ ] like good and bad but like people
didn't really understand the scope of
like the work you know you know how long
an NFL football season is and it was
like covert year like the cover year
wasn't an easy year for nobody so it was
my first year in Buffalo and if you ask
anybody at this time you know like
everything went white in it everything
went right at that point you know I'm
saying up to that point so as I see like
I said I got The Perfect story you know
I got traded here things are going great
we got a good team we got a great
quarterback we going to the show I'm
saying and I'm I'm not thinking nobody
in my way so as we get to the FC
Championship I was like this [ __ ] like
I'm saying like all right another test
for us we're gonna get through this
because the playoff run we had we beat
the Colts we beat Baltimore yeah I'm
like this [ __ ] like we ain't walking
through stuff but we we figuring it out
excuse me so in that moment it was
definitely something that was
heart-wrenching something that like it
hurt me the most because to see
everything go right and then in one of
the biggest moments for us to get to the
next level I'm saying that's that's why
I aspire to be I want to play in the
Super Bowl I want to do everything I can
I felt short of it and I felt like I
didn't do enough
and then like in that moment I just
wanted to really gasp or bring it for a
circle to be like this okay you put all
that work in you still need to see I'm
saying you need to be motivated you need
to be pushed because I it's crazy you
got you ask God for something he'd give
it to you and I ask God before every
every game continue to motivate me
continue to push me to be a better
player you know that obviously was
something that pushed me and then like
it was crazy because [ __ ] next year that
we played him
um I think like we fell short again or
we felt short or whatever in the Long
Haul and I'm like this [ __ ] like what
can I do different and it's up to this
point I'm like this still
you're not it's not it's a team game
you're saying it's not just one person
and you got a great Supporting Cast like
I got a great group of receivers I got a
great quarterback so me putting in
perspective I'm like this yes I want to
do everything I can for this team but be
you you know I'm saying I had to I had
to be like be you I'm saying play your
road whatever it is you know I'm saying
whatever our game requires you just be
that like and don't try to bite off more
than you can true because you can't do
everybody's job you know I'm saying
that's their job and they do a great job
at it so why not just trust them so man
we're gonna get their fam 100 percent
we're gonna get there man I don't like
making promises bro but when you got
teammates they work the way you work and
you got teammates like Josh and
everything like we're gonna get there we
gonna get there I'm gonna do everything
I possibly can in my power to uplift my
teammates and me personally like I'm
gonna do everything for us to get there
it's a great moment I'm gonna win the
Super Bowl it's like football Heaven
that's how I described it to you know
the Rams last year and when you got the
confetti dropping and they play that NFL
Network film they played it down when
you're walking out there film and it's
just one of those moments that you want
like
I don't want like my brothers and my
colleagues to feel that moment it's
football Heaven that [ __ ] go down
forever fam and I'm gonna do everything
I can to get their family we will get
there I'm all about positive yeah you
know talking positive affirmations bro
we're gonna get there fam we can run the
footage back oh yeah we can play it it
might not happen how we wanted it to
happen bro but it's gonna happen bro for
sure I'm with you
um you know you had another viral moment
it might not be you but it you know it
was your nephew it was his nephew
meeting Dak and um is your nephew it was
your nephew Aiden and he's his favorite
quarterback is that but he he nervously
mistooken
yeah man that's if you if you know my
nephew
I don't know I don't want to say this
but like he might have been trying to be
funny because my nephew has like such a
big personality if you just have a
conversation with him he could have been
just trying to be funny like in that
moment because but he is still a little
kid so you never know but I've been
around him and he say like little slick
stuff to me and I'm like well I beat you
up type Bob so uh he's definitely one of
those kids that big personality he needs
to he needs to be on a podcast at one
point he needs to have a conversation
because he has a lot to say and say he
has a big person he's respectful and
that's my little man I might have to
beat him up still but that's my little
man you gotta tell you um bro but I've
seen I seen some some dope Clips I was
watching he said um you know he was
watching Trayvon play and he was like
believe in yourself yeah you can just
tell like the relationship that Trayvon
got with his son like that's the type of
[ __ ] that I want to have with my son I
want to tell him like to always believe
in yourself and for him to pay it
forward back to his dad on the side
that's amazing that [ __ ] was super cool
man he's speaking of Trayvon oh yeah my
man what's it like having a brother in
the NFL
and how are you both finding success I
know y'all had like some talks when
y'all was growing up like what is it
like to like be here in this moment have
a brother in the NFL and both of y'all
having success yeah you know you on a
cold team here on the code team like
yeah that's it that [ __ ] really crazy
because like growing up like when we was
in like middle school or high school
like
like I always had the vision like going
to the NFL like all like us all the guys
that we had no plan made it it was Zero
Plan B I was going into the NFL all this
other [ __ ] that y'all got going on this
is what I want to do you know I'm saying
I get it I get it there's ways we got to
do XYZ but I'm going in the NFL and it
was the same for my little brother it's
like I feel like
I ain't gonna say I paid these steps
because he walked he walked his own line
you know saying I just try to lead him
to the best to the best way I knew so
it's like to see him mature in the
process like I went to I stayed home for
him because I want to kind of stay close
to him and then when it was his time he
went to Alabama and I was like damn I
probably should have went away [ __ ] but
I watched him out Alabama go through a
maturation process of his own too like
he had got injured he played a little
bit and he went to be in the starting
corner and having had a success so to
see my little brother do that
then get drafted to our childhood team
like Dallas was where we grew up like
come on two years so it's like [ __ ]
crazy it's like this damn like little
bro just got drafted to Dallas and it
was like a full circle moment I used
he's crazy bring up Aiden before the
draft my brother had like 30 hats like
at the teams you know how you know how
it is but you all probably have two hats
because
I thought I just knew I was going
through it
so uh before before my brother got
drafted his son said he going here and
he picked up the Cowboys video of it so
it's like damn like he really picked out
the Cowboys had my brother got drafted
to the Cowboys and then like as he got
in the league he had his first year and
he had dropped like five picks and I'm
like damn you forgot how to play
receiver that quick because he played
receiver in college until he's like that
last two years then as a next year he
went crazy right yeah
11 11 picks so I said if you if you
caught half of the ball that you dropped
you at least had 10 picks he was like
don't worry about it bro I'm gonna get
my hands on him this year and like he
had game out of the game picks after
pick two picks like I'm like this he
going crazy like so I took a step back
from being like his brother now became
like a real fan like I'm talking [ __ ]
like I played like I'm rooting for the
Cowboys like even on my team like guys
are like this your brother ain't gonna
pick you I forgot who it was last year
it was against the Patriots they was
like throwing at him but they wasn't
really throwing at him and I was like
did he do for one don't worry about it
it'll come when it's supposed to happen
he got a pick late in the game and they
ended up winning and I was like that I
told y'all so just to have that ability
to talk [ __ ] behind my little brother
him saying it's like damn like my little
brother really him you know I'm saying
it's not like it's not like I'm I'm a
decent player my brother got some drop
off my brother's so nice damn it's I
feel like my mom should have should have
saved some of them eggs or something
because like yeah
I'd have been around Trey bro I'd
probably spend more time around Trey
than I have like you of course now we're
on the same team I spent more time
around you but you know for both of
y'all to be brothers bro like [ __ ] must
have been like dope growing up bro but
he did he did say that you know if he
played y'all if he played you he would
like he would lock you down and he said
if y'all you know he said if he plays
y'all then he would lock you down like
if y'all had 10 reps one-on-one you know
I don't want it because I got a brother
too I had another one I said you know
how this [ __ ] though you know how to say
if you if you had 10 reps against your
brother like what you think I probably
let him win like two because that spam
yeah this is my little brother like I
want I always tell them like so you have
older brother or a younger brother I got
a younger brother so look you can attest
is this true I call that little brother
syndrome like or like a little brother
curse that they really can't beat you in
nothing like that they'll get close to
being you but a lot of the time they
can't beat you and I think it's like I
play my little brother in Madden and all
those games a million times but he'll
get close and then in here like he'll
like [ __ ] it up it's gonna be something
mental
you got a little brother syndrome it
happens you're not gonna be able to beat
me maybe one day so I think that's going
to apply the same [ __ ] we play a game
yes uh if I win the battle I won the war
it was uh we better win that game but if
I win that battle I could talk [ __ ] for
the rest of it bro I'm like that with my
little brother too and I'm like bro you
know now we're to the point we both like
we both grown and [ __ ] like we kind of
took a step back but but growing up
we're like I want to win everything like
especially it's my little brother we he
two years younger than me we go to the
same school we on the same football team
like I just I want to win everything but
if it's him like versus somebody else
and I'm all oh yeah for sure but yeah
you know if it's me and him like I gotta
I gotta put that down
speaking of little brothers like Josh
Allen is is like one of your little
brothers to a family too like what has
he meant to your career I know we talked
about it earlier what does he meant to
your career for real [ __ ] like uh like
damn near everything like I ain't gonna
happen Ain't No Cap when I say that
because Shawty excuse me Shawty really
like I say like changed my career like
from where I was and to how I'm viewed
now like I always saw myself as that
player but I like it was hard to put the
pen to paper because my stats wasn't
imagining you know I'm saying my play
was good but was it like him as good
like I used to run good routes like you
know I'm saying [ __ ] like that but I
really wanted to cement myself as one of
the best players not the best receiver
in the league so when I first got to
Buffalo it was like it worked in tandem
like Josh Allen needed a wide receiver
one like he was saying he had some good
assets here like Josh John Brown was a
hell of a receiver um but they needed
something I'm saying and when I came
there I just they embraced me being
myself like as you can see like they
embrace you being yourself like you
ain't got to be nobody else but yourself
that's it and that's it so when I saw
that and when I first met him I tell
people this story all the time he said
stuff like I was like this like I think
you're a good ass quarterback like I
really do like I'm saying like I'm not
Captain when I say that he said I'm not
gonna ask much of you much of you and I
was like so what's up what you need he
was like just get open and catch the
ball he's like I don't care how you do
it I don't care no no just get open
let's catch the ball and I was like [ __ ]
you sure cause it's like it's way easier
I said you sure and he was like he was
like yeah I was like [ __ ] and from that
point on we was hoping and then up to
this point now it's like this [ __ ] how
good can we be I'm saying because if you
got a good quarterback you got something
you know what I'm saying and I'm
grateful because I've had some good
quarterbacks in the past shout out to
him but this that quarterback that I
that God had for me at the end of the
tunnel like it did I got something for
you just make sure you sharpening your
blade when it's time it's gonna it's
gonna cut 100 bro what what makes what
makes Josh special and what makes you
want to go what makes you want to grow
old with Josh we told him that last week
kind of turned red a little bit yeah
oh [ __ ]
um probably because he's still like a
little brother like yes I have a little
I have a younger sibling but he's like a
big little brother like he's still got
the he's still playful he's still like
got that maturation process that you've
seen him grow from a good player to like
one of those exceptional players like
MVP Canada shout outs he's gonna be the
NBA that's in my opinion right now the
thing's looking he blowing [ __ ] out the
water so it's like he was in the mix
last year for just as far as like to see
him have success until I kind of see us
grow together that's coming from that
little brother in that family mindset
because it's like this damn like we kind
of like came up together like you you
the man now you know I'm saying I'm
pulling for him in in ways that people
won't imagine it's just like this damn
bro to see him have successes like this
like you really that you really that boy
you know what I'm saying and he deserve
it like how he carry herself
he's a I call him the Will Ferrell of
quarterback I said you know he bro he
joke about everything like he take no he
don't take nothing serious bro like he
do he do [ __ ] his way bro and it's is
dope to be around you know both of y'all
bro it's dope it's dope to be in the
[ __ ] locker room every day with Coach
McDermott only care about winning I
think Josh kind of rub off on coaching
100 I think I think he used to be a
tough guy back in the day I heard I
heard Joshua he like super cool now
because of Josh when I got there also
too I was like this they were saying
like he was like a little bit more like
tight like on XYZ and I was like [ __ ]
like I ain't really seen it he's like
this yeah he's he loosening up a little
bit especially when you got here too
like Josh got Josh got that effect on
people also I think too so even in the
game like he had that big play in the
beginning of the game and then he had
threw an interception like you know him
and Gabe was just wasn't on the same
page on something like it was like a
21-yard line we had converted it to some
small receiver talk so
coming back he was like this you know
when a guy gets a pick like he usually
quarterback is like man I ain't throwing
over there no more [ __ ] that yeah I'm
I'm trying to protect my stats or
whatever he is he has zero of that
mindset he was like this we had another
big play Gabe had caught up with one
hand out of the catch by the way hey
shout out to Gabe okay bro 170. he's
saying he said he said he said don't
worry about it we're going we're going
to go right back at him to Gabe and I'm
like this this month this [ __ ]
is crazy
but he's just a dog and like he put us
in a situation he'd give you confidence
as a receiver like [ __ ] okay some stuff
ain't gonna go right but don't worry
about it we're gonna come back to you
and we're gonna hit him where it hurt
for sure man um I think you know one I
want to ask you this one thing that the
viewers would be surprised to hear about
Josh that they didn't know before but I
know last week we talked about them we
talked about him throwing up too I was
surprised yeah I wasn't surprised
because throughout this
out it's a preseason like you know I'll
be walking in there and I just hear
no yeah
I expected now you just expect to like
yeah if you ain't here if you don't hear
somebody like gagging in the background
what's going on what's going on so would
that be something that you would say I
would have shared that too like that's
something that don't nobody really know
but he got that really be me you know
will he beat me you should throw up in
the Huddle but at least he has enough
respect to throw up like before the game
type [ __ ] so I'll check on them like all
right all right you threw up yet he was
like hit me like this uh nah not yet I'm
like this let's hurry get that [ __ ] out
of the way because I ain't trying to
hear that [ __ ] in the Huddle because
he'll throw up sometimes before the game
and then kind of like when he first get
out there yeah I'm like this boy why the
[ __ ] you so nervous you go out here and
who like sure but it's like he got that
that little kid like that you know I'm
saying before game a little bit of
jitters and it's like that he got her
Earl so I [ __ ] with it though man for me
like when I hear that like at this point
in my career because I used to be that
guy and my and mine used to be just off
anxiety because on teams that I was on
if I didn't get a Sac Force film or
phone recovery touchdown we might not
win the game even if I do do that like
it still might be a competition so it
was it wasn't pressure of
of it wasn't pressure from the outside
world it's just pressure for myself like
like I have to go out here and ball so I
used to be in that environment and like
I used to feel like that before games so
now being like year 12 and like being
where I'm at mentally like when I hear
that I just be like okay like yeah I'm
about to go out here and ball out I got
I got this don't even trip like get it I
got it nice now now it's like bro I'm
about to go ahead and win a game by
myself
just do it just do what you do found
like I'm gonna do it for us fam so it's
just become one of those things that you
want to hear fam you want to hear
something crazy my first game my first
game I ever played
was against the Denver Broncos oh yeah
and over yeah y'all won the Super Bowl
oh that's crazy I got to play against no
flies that was Teddy right yeah I gotta
Vegas no fly zone I played against you
Shane Shane right yeah DeMarcus Ware
that was Shane first check that game too
I was watching like I went back and
watched that game not too long ago just
some highlights and I was like damn that
was my first game and that's when I my
first game is when I kind of like was
close to winning the job to be playing
on a consistent basis so I was like this
my first game was against the Super Bowl
championships and that was a good y'all
team was good as [ __ ] that Peyton
Manning ran yeah like that was a team
full of yeah ap2 right yeah yeah yeah
he didn't really have a lot that day but
he had bust one or two and I was like
the they got a good ass team and now
looking back and coming full circle
looking at our team kind of similar to
the team y'all have saying like a
different different quarterback play a
little bit you know saying a little
younger than paid but the factors that
make a Super Bowl team we got are there
and I'm like this damn that it came full
circle again
we we always like to you know end you
know my my podcast we're asking my guys
you know who are the who are the top
five defenses that you face or the top
five corners or a little bit of both
like if it's a top five defense and they
got this guy like what who gives you
nobody give you really like trouble like
that but you know who presents the most
adversity whenever you plan them yeah
I'll give you both my top five defenses
I'm gonna give it to you in general too
because like I remember being young and
I was like damn these [ __ ] are
good
that Denver team was one of the best
defenses I played against going against
the team yes when y'all won the Super
Bowl it's like a keep to lead you know
saying the grown when it came to this
ain't no young you know what I'm saying
it's like you know [ __ ] Chris Harris
Chris Harris you know I'm saying people
don't really know but people in football
know how good Chris Harris really is
because hers is one of the top DBS in
the league for a long time so I went to
get Chris Harris I wanted his key to
leave and I went to Bradley Roby you
know what I'm saying so at that time I
was like this [ __ ] like I really took a
lot of lumps as a young kid that I see
receivers now might not ever take you
know I'm saying but I took it on the
chin because like I felt like it was
going to make me better so like Denver
was a was a tough task Seattle was a
tough task back then like you know how
good it is Richard Sherman and all that
all those guys I was like this damn like
when I first got in the league it was
weird because in college you these you
think these guys are in the league it's
like it's kind of like far removed but
as I got into that money damn I'm
playing against these [ __ ] I
got a who like I gotta I gotta
contribute so uh him
a prime a prime Pastor Peterson is
really still one of the best DBS to ever
play the game uh in my opinion
um and now in today's game I'll give you
my [ __ ] my my top
that's a couple defenses but we play
some defenses now uh Kansas City
obviously presumes some type of
difficulty because I'm saying they do so
many different things and I'm saying if
they trying to take you out of the game
this is like as a receiver that's
possible you know what I'm saying you
can do whatever you can to try to get
the ball
um and having that offensive mind and
those OCS it really helps yeah but uh
Casey is obviously one of the good
defenses who else did we do we play
[ __ ] I thought La was a good team too
no matter what the score yeah
I was over there with them boys like I
didn't I knew that's why I kept saying
like don't blink don't blink because at
any given moment they can be right back
100 uh
but my I give you my top my top corners
in the league is obviously Jalen
Ramsey's one uh one of the top guys I
try not to do one to five just like one
one yeah yeah you don't have the right
Jaylen Ramsey uh Xavier Xavier is one of
the best DBS in the league like for sure
get a lot of get a lot of uh get a lot
of love especially from the people in
the league
um Darius Slay it's crazy because I
played against something when I was in
Minnesota we used to battle it out I
said Detroit and I'm like damn this
[ __ ] good like he's like cool he
quick he fast you know he's still strong
and like he's one of the best TV uh slay
um obviously you know what I'm saying I
gotta say because he is nice my little
brother
being my family I think he's very
exceptional at the DB position and I'm
trying to remember one more guy I think
uh my our guy Ferreira
um he might be he might be at the very
incentive top two top three when healthy
is to Davis
he he he's one of the people I see work
extremely hard and it translates so um
those my top guys I might be leaving
some guys out but my bad on the
defensive tip you know I work out well
yeah
and I'm gonna end it
with a little trivia game oh they didn't
want to play
yeah we call this the Minneapolis
Miracle trivia game all right I'm not
gonna put you on the clock or nothing
but I got let me see one two three
o'clock on six seven I got seven
questions I want to ask I'm clutch on
Family Feud too if you know Family Feud
I got this is my first question
how much time
was on the clock when the ball snapped
he said it uh
14 [ __ ] he was close ten ten seconds
damn I know it was something shorter
than that it was about 10 seconds bro I
was trying to get out of bounds like
when I caught it I was like [ __ ] he
gonna hit me let me just fight my way
out of bouncing and I just felt somebody
like not hit me he blinked bro he had to
Blink yeah
the ball rolled his team is don't blink
when I felt somebody blink I swear to
God said boy we go home
what down was it
[ __ ]
we have a lot of time
it was 30 days
okay I'm gonna get I'm gonna get you one
right here what what color jersey was
you wearing oh I should have seen it
purple yeah
all right what about this one what what
cleats did you have on uh uh I know I
know um the DS2 the future cleats yeah
yeah it's a Dirty Sprite too that you
know I was going up before the game too
close
I listen to both of them but for every
game the two closest Defenders when you
caught the ball
um my man that's from the city uh Kenny
Kenny something
he's having a good ass career too like
aside from that play like you can see
him he had like a nice bounce back like
he having a good ass career he in
Baltimore actually
celebration as you cross the goal on oh
yeah I tossed that [ __ ] like I
was uh what's that thing are you not in
the team I think I was like a show bro
we need to make that a movie
first person that you hugged after
uh he hugged me uh it's one of my it's
my one of my close friends you know we
were real close back in the day it was
Caleb Jones like
um he was like one of those guys that
was pulling for me during the year like
was watching me kind of battle that
mental process of like [ __ ] not going
right I'm like [ __ ] and he's just like
it's gonna be all right bro watch this
gonna work out it's gonna work out so he
was ran on the field and gave me the
biggest hug I was like this man I love
you bro it was it was lit that's hard
but the relationship that you build with
your teammates and [ __ ] bro it ain't
nothing like it bro and yeah you know
they bro you know they want to talk they
want to talk about the Chiefs man it's
all right you know this
so we like to we like to do our we like
to have every we like to have a song
title for every we talk we like the tree
last season like an album 100 so if you
had to if you had to name this week's
um song title versus the Chiefs what
would that what would that song title be
let's see let me see I might have
something let me look right here
um
something had just dropped
Bullseye too
[Laughter]
you know a lot of bills fans had this
circle you know yeah they wanted to see
it off the road we're going we're going
to see them again 100 I like boys I
don't like I mean I don't want to take
you know Boston Richie you know but song
Hard bro we had to take it bro boys out
too Bullseye 2.0 yeah you know they how
are we treating this week's preparation
[ __ ] his coach would say I'm saying
which also like you said just don't
blink you know we going into it with the
right mindset hostile environment you
know I feel like this team kind of falls
in love with that hostile environment
I'm saying we built to win and we got to
do the necessary preparation during the
week like he kind of gave us a lot of
information as far as like what are we
doing in the next one so it's just like
focus on this week and take it one play
at a time one day at a time and he gonna
ask for execution because we're gonna
need a high level of execution in order
to win this game offensively and
defensively man and we know you know the
Bills fans had this one Circle you know
a long time ago after you know what
happened in the playoffs like you know
this is a different season different
year both teams are different but I know
we both looking forward to this game you
know this is uh this is the biggest game
of the year because it's the next game
you know so we're gonna take this one
super serious like we've been doing all
season long stick to the plan taking one
play at a time and always don't blink
and I appreciate you for having me on
the show bro
cast man y'all tuning in and on a
special guest you said what we're going
have Travis Kelsey next yeah we gotta
have Travis bro you got to get out here
man we're gonna get him on here man
we're gonna get them on appreciate you
the show my boy
[Music]